now more bad news for joe biden tonight
a new poll from fox business found that
a whopping 7 in 10 americans think 2021
was a bad year for the country and it
doesn't stop there according to a new
poll from the morning council just 10
percent of voters say democratic
accomplishments more than they expected
surge in inflation rising energy costs
with no end in sight it's a stark
reminder of the failure of joe biden's
and the failure of the democratic agenda
and get this according to a new cnn poll
biden's economic numbers have cratered
to a point even lower than jimmy carter
exposes just how much americans are
losing confidence in the biden
presidency here now the reaction
wisconsin senator ron johnson senator
thanks so much for joining us tonight um
i i think a lot of voters are starting
to have
buyers remorse because they say
that joe doesn't only not have the
stamina but everything that he promised
as far as being a moderate he straight
up lots of american people and now he
wants to blame your colleague joe
manchin
well hello lawrence and merry christmas
let me first start by saying it's so
refreshing to hear dr ben carson
uh st you know coming out and speaking
out and being a voice of reason we we
need one when it comes to covet but to
answer your question uh democrat
governance the bite administration has
been a disaster for america started
immediately when he canceled the
keystone xl pipeline that certainly
contributed to rising gas prices he
opened the borders so we had this record
surge of illegal immigration the
embarrassing and dangerous uh surrender
in afghanistan and then you know their
only solution is spending more money and
that's a double whammy not only do you
create way more you know way more
dollars chasing too few goods so that
that's the definition of inflation but
you're spending those dollars to make it
possible for people not to re-engage in
the workforce so you don't have
manufacturers can hire enough people so
that also exacerbates the supply of
goods so
the policies of the of the democrats
this is what we are seeing the results
of but is there policy yeah i i
it's accurate to call the byte
administration incompetent but that's
way too kind these are their policies
the results of their policies were
obvious from the start and now americans
are waking up to it yeah they are
i want to take you to your colleague joe
manchin you know him um what was going
on behind the scenes because it seemed
like to me that he was very transparent
or where on where he stood on this piece
of election legislation he thought it
was way too much spending uh he
communicated that to the white house he
communicated that to the american public
but it seems like the biden
administration
weren't willing to you know compromise
on the issue and when he said he was
done they decided to have his staffers
go out there and leak and smear this man
yeah it sounded to me like he laid out
in in very great detail what he'd accept
and the by administration and democrats
in congress just simply figured they
could just pressure him into rolling and
uh just accepting whatever they tried to
shove down his throat and then of course
they developed
a plan of incredibly dishonest scoring
scoring something that really is about
five trillion dollars in spending to
score that at 1.75 trillion dollars and
when the cbo score came out uh joe
manchin said i just can't buy this plus
he was highly concerned about inflation
as we all should be a 6.8
consumer price index over the last 12
months 9.75
producer price index
this is a disaster for the very people
democrats purport to represent
seniors on fixed income and people at
the lower end of our income spectrum
inflation hurts them the most you know
mark zuckerberg and jeff bezos they're
not going to be harmed by inflation uh
they're rolling in the dough based on
these coveted shutdowns it's the poor
people it's it's the elderly that are
really hurt by inflation again inflation
caused by democrat policies
you know senator i got to ask you
because you know it seems like the
republicans are going to take back the
house you got a possibility of taking
back the senate so when you get the
power back in your hand
what are you going to do for the
american people because they don't want
any of this squishy nonsense they want
people that are going to be strong for
america first agenda what's the what's
the agenda for you guys if y'all take
back the house
well i think we should you know continue
with the successful trump agenda reduce
regulation make sure that we maintain a
competitive tax system and by and large
stay out the backs of the american
public let them live their lives let
them build their businesses let them
produce products and services we all
value and try and get the federal
government out of their lives as much as
possible it's successful that's what
works that's what made america great
our freedom our ability to dream aspire
build and create not big government
you know it's a simple formula senator
let's just hope your colleagues follow
it thank you so much for joining us on
hannah tonight
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmea and i'm
ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis